[Music]
foreign
so I have been in the studio all day
today it is getting late but I have
stuck with it here because I am super
excited about this next lecture uh we're
going to start solving these generic
systems of equations x dot equals ax
using eigenvalues and eigenvectors so
I'll just put that up solving x dot
equals ax with
eigenvalues
and eigenvectors
eigenvectors
and I'd say this is one of the
culminations of all of kind of
introductory applied math linear algebra
and differential equations is going to
be covered in this and the next two
lectures where we really break down how
to solve Matrix Systems of differential
equations using eigenvalues and
eigenvectors
specifically I am actually going to
derive the eigenvalue and eigenvector
equation as a necessary coordinate
transformation to simplify this
differential equation so this lecture is
going to end on kind of deriving from
scratch the equation from which we
obtain eigenvalues and eigenvectors
specifically to solve this this system
okay so I'm going to write out the
objective I'm going to solve a simple
case and then we're going to jump into
eigenvalues and eigenvectors
so we basically want to solve we want
to solve
a generic system of equations a general
General
system
of ordinary differential equations x dot
equals ax system of equations
equations
uh and specifically
X is a vector of States now there are
multiple you know X1 X2 X3 X4 multiple
components of this Vector x a is a
matrix and this is a system of coupled
first order linear ordinary differential
equations first order because we only
have one derivative in time coupled
because presumably these derivatives
depend on all of the other states in
this Vector X
and linearly linear because this
derivative x dot is a linear combination
of the states in X that's literally what
a matrix times a vector means that's a
linear combination okay
um and so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to start off with the simplest
possible case where this a matrix is
diagonal meaning that the Dynamics are
decoupled okay so uh kind of case one
case one is where what we have what we
call decoupled Dynamics decoupled
decoupled Dynamics I'll tell you what
that means
so remember when we had
um
kind of our first example of a
differential equation x dot equals
Lambda X the example we introduced was
the population of bunnies and Bunny
populations grow exponentially
what I mean by decoupled Dynamics is
going to be let's say that the state X
refers to the populations of different
animals but they are kind of in a zoo so
they're each cordoned off into different
zones and so that they don't interact
that's what I mean by decoupled so we're
going to have the populations of like
bunnies and wolves tools and Antelope
and so I'm going to have a state Vector
with multiple populations and they're
each going to behave linearly but
they're only going to depend on
themselves they're not going to be
coupled yet so I like to call this kind
of you know my example I think about is
a different
animals
in a zoo
and it's a zoo that's big enough where
they can grow exponentially it's kind of
like a Hilbert's zoo or something like
that
okay so the populations are separate
that's the key things that the
populations are separate and so I'm
going to write down this differential
equation so we have
let's say our state Vector X has a bunch
of components X1 X2
dot dot dot all the way to X N let's say
I have n animals in N different zones in
this zoo and I'm taking D DT
of this state Vector that's just this is
just x dot where X is a big Vector
containing all of these components
and we're going to say that this equals
in the case of decoupled Dynamics
this is again a matrix a times
X1 X2 dot dot dot xn
but now what we're going to have is that
this is going to be a diagonal matrix so
X1 dot is only going to be a function of
X1 we're going to call that let's say
you know Lambda 1 0 dot dot dot zero
the second animal let's say X1 or bunny
population
let's call that our wolves X2 dot is
only going to be a function of X2
because they live in their own you know
room in this big Zoo so they actually
are not interacting with the bunnies so
they have no influence X1 has no
influence on on X2 X2 dot is only equal
to uh com to a number times X2 we're
going to call that number Lambda 2. so
X2 dot equals Lambda 2 x 2 and that's
the only uh these are decoupled so you
know the wolves are alone the bunnies
are alone dot dot dot it's very lonely I
actually think they're fine with uh you
know all the bunnies together
and then
um
kind of every term is like this and now
the X N Dynamics the nth population
whatever uh only depends on the X N
population with this Lambda n
proportionality
so this is really really simple
um in some case I didn't even need to
write this as a system of differential
equations in a matrix form I could have
literally just written this as so before
I forget I'm going to call this Matrix
D because it's diagonal and decoupled
okay so this is a special case of an a
matrix where it's diagonal and decoupled
I didn't even have to
write it like this I could have
literally just written down you know X
One Dot equals Lambda 1 x 1 x 2 dot
equals Lambda 2 x 2 dot dot dot x n dot
equals Lambda n x n and of course we
already know the solution of this we can
just solve them each independently we
could say that X 1 at time T is e to the
Lambda 1 T times X1
my initial condition X1 naught and x 2
at time T is equal to e to the Lambda 2
t
times that initial wolf population X2
knot
all the way down to xn at time T equals
e to the Lambda n t times x n not the
initial population of that nth uh you
know animal population
and so these are really easy because my
Dynamics are decoupled
it's almost trivial for me to solve the
system of equations and if I like I can
write this solution again in Matrix form
I can just say you know this is
um
X
1 x 2 dot dot dot x n this big Vector X
at time T is equal to and now I have a
diagonal matrix of of exponentials I
have e to the Lambda 1 t 0 dot dot dot
zero I have zero e to the Lambda 2 T dot
dot dot zero
so this should be pretty you know
intuitive at this point zero zero e to
the Lambda n t
times my initial conditions times you
know X1 X2 dot dot dot X and this Vector
evaluated at Time Zero
and so this is really really simple this
uh if this Matrix here was d a diagonal
matrix then this Matrix here is
e
to the diagonal matrix T okay it's
literally a diagonal matrix where I
exponentiate all of the diagonal
elements times T this is e to the D T I
haven't defined what a matrix
exponential is yet I'll Define that in a
couple of lectures it's really easy you
literally take the Taylor series for you
know e to the X and you just plug in a
matrix for x and you work it out that's
how you take Matrix exponentials and
this is what you get for decoupled
Dynamics
okay so this is really really really
easy to solve my system of equations x
dot equals ax if a is a diagonal matrix
d
good so I hope I've convinced you that
that's really really easy okay this is
the full solution
well they're not going to be nice and
diagonal like this you know you're not
going to be dealing with animals in a
zoo you're going to be dealing with the
populations of bunnies and wolves and
Antelope in the wild and they're not
going to be separated they're going to
be interacting with each other so
there's going to be cross terms in this
Matrix and in general a is not going to
be diagonal it's going to be a full
gnarly Matrix and it's not going to be
easy to solve it like this okay and so
that's where
eigenvalues and eigenvectors are going
to come in what we're going to try to do
is we are going to try to find a
coordinate transformation that turns
this system into a diagonal decoupled
system I'm going to erase this and then
write that out one second
okay so we now know that it's easy to
solve these Matrix systems of equations
if the Matrix a relating all of my
derivatives to all of my States is
diagonal and decoupled
so now the objective here is going to be
for this generic system for
a general system
for a general system
x dot equals a x
what we're going to try to do we want a
change of coordinates we
want a new coordinate system or a change
of coordinates
a change of coordinates
and I'm going to write this as
X
equals t
times Z so T is going to be a matrix an
invertible Matrix a matrix that has
non-zero determinant so you can compute
its inverse so I can go from X to Z or Z
to X by multiplying by The Matrix t or
its inverse so I want a change of
coordinates into a new coordinate system
Z
that diagonalizes my ordinary
differential equation that
diagonalizes diagonalizes
diagonalizes my ode
specifically what I want
in this z-coordinate system I want Z Dot
to equal a diagonal decoupled matrix
times Z okay that's my entire objective
now if I have a generic system if
someone hands me a system and they say
hey Steve can you model this system I'm
going to first try to find a coordinate
transformation T that goes back and
forth from from you know from x
coordinates into a z coordinate system
where in this coordinate system my
Dynamics are decoupled and diagonal
because here I could easily solve this
we know how to solve this Z as a
function of time is e to the Matrix d
times time
my initial conditions I know how to
solve this this is easy to solve we just
did it so now I'm going to try to find
this coordinate transformation that
diagonalizes my system okay and
specifically we're going to do this and
we're going to derive the eigenvalue and
eigenvector equation
so I'm going to take the time derivative
of both sides of this thing
maybe I'll go orange here for a minute
so I'm going to take the time derivative
of both sides and I'm going to take t
[Music]
Z dot that equals x dot
and x dot equals ax so that equals uh
a x and so that implies that t z dot
equals ax
and specifically x equals TZ so here I
can plug it I'm trying to get an
equation for Z
so I can basically say that t
Z dot equals a times x and that's a
times T times Z this equals a times t
times Z and now we'll remember to put
all of these matrices and vectors so big
capital letters generally I use to mean
matrices so a and t are matrices Z and X
are vectors okay that's my the state of
my system x and z is the state of my
system in some different coordinate
system okay and I'll tell you what I
mean by a different coordinate system in
a minute okay so now this is starting to
get somewhere now we have a differential
equation only in Z but I have this pesky
T out here so I'm going to try to invert
this T and and multiply on both sides by
that
so that gives me
uh Z Dot
equals T inverse a
t
times Z
and remember I'm specifically trying to
find this coordinate I'm trying to find
this Matrix T that's what I mean by a
coordinate transformation it's just a
matrix T linear coordinate
Transformations are matrix
multiplication that's what linear
algebra tells us and so specifically I'm
trying to find a t Matrix so that this
quantity here is a diagonal matrix so
that Z dot equals this stuff here is
diagonal times Z
and so specifically like we can we can
write this uh pretty simply we want
we want
a t Matrix
so that
uh
so that
t
inverse a t
equals this diagonal matrix okay that's
what we want
okay it's all writing all these double
under bars is getting a little tedious
but I'm going to stick with it because I
think it's important so we want a t so
that this is true we had this system we
want to find a coordinate transformation
that diagonalizes our Dynamics and if we
had a t
so that t inverse a t equals the
diagonal matrix we've done it okay and
so the last step is actually like very
very simple the last step here is I'm
just going to multiply both sides Again
by T invert by by on the left by T to
kill this T inverse
and so that is going to give me
a t
equals t
d
I multiplied the left by T on both sides
so I get a t equals t d
these are matrices
this is
the eigenvalue and eigenvector equation
this is the this is the eigenvalue
equation
eigenvalue
equation
I'm going to put some big exclamation
marks because this is a huge deal
literally
the diagonal elements of D the diagonal
elements
of d
are the eigenvalues eigenvalues
of a
and the columns
The Columns of t
are the
eigenvectors
of a okay D is a matrix a is a matrix so
I haven't shown you how to solve for T
and D that's a whole another lecture I'm
going to do that next we're going to
we're going to show how for a specific a
matrix we can find these eigenvalues in
D and the eigenvectors in t but this is
the equation the equation
that I'm solving for T is so that my
Dynamics become diagonal
those T are the eigenvectors of a that's
exactly what this means this is the
eigenvalue eigenvector equation so for
me I always found it very
counterintuitive that you take a linear
algebra class and they write down all
this abstract kind of algebra and they
write down here's what an eigenvalue and
eigenvector is without motivating it
for me this is why we care about
eigenvalues and eigenvectors in the
first place this is why I care about
eigenvalues and eigenvectors because
eigenvectors of a matrix change are a
change of coordinates so that it becomes
diagonal these eigenvectors provide a
change of coordinates in these
eigenvector coordinates my Dynamics are
diagonal that's huge that means I can
solve any linear system of equations
okay so I'm almost done I think what I'm
going to do now is I'm literally going
to draw a picture of this for you so I'm
going to say I'm going to draw a picture
of this eigenvalue equation and then I'm
going to you know end this lecture
and in the next lecture we're going to
figure out how do you compute these
things and then how do you use these T's
and D's specifically to solve this
equation and then to go back and write
it in terms of my original x coordinates
which is where you know I probably
measured things and where I actually
care about things
Okay so
so um I have my a matrix here
I'm just going to draw it as a big
Square matrix it's an N by n Matrix okay
that's a
this T Matrix
has columns you know T1 T2 dot dot dot
all the way up to TN these are column
vectors
where each column vector
is an eigenvector of a
and this is equaling
now I maybe Drew this just a tiny tiny
tiny bit too tall that's going to be a
problem okay these are the eigenvectors
of a let's
give myself a little more room here
so a times t equals T times d
so this is going to equal again
T1 T2 dot dot dot all the way up to T N
this is again my T Matrix
times D my my diagonal matrix okay and
my diagonal matrix again just had these
these lambdas these eigenvalues um
sometimes in my notes I call them D1 D2
D3 I'm here I'm just going to call them
Lambda 1 Lambda 2 Lambda 1 Lambda 2 dot
dot dot Lambda n
zeros everywhere else
and here's what I want to point out
is that
if I take this
um
a column of this so if I want to
multiply this matrix by this Matrix what
I do is I take the First Column of D and
I kind of knock it over on its side and
multiply it by every row of t
that's my first column
then I take the second column of d i
knock it over on its side and I multiply
it by all of the rows of T that's my
second column and so on and so forth but
if you take let's say this Lambda 2 you
know this column here
and I knock it over on its side and
multiply it because it's zeros
everywhere else it's only going to
multiply
the t2 eigenvector so this is a very
useful property of this diagonal matrix
this literally is going to equal
Lambda 1 T1 that vector
Lambda 2 T2
that Vector dot dot dot Lambda n t n
that Vector okay and so what we're
basically going to find is that a times
T1 is going to equal Lambda 1 t 1. a
times T2 the second column of this
product is going to equal Lambda 2 T2
and so on and so forth I'm going to get
a bunch of of equations that look like a
times T equals Lambda times T okay like
for the kth eigenvector and the kth
eigenvalue this is going to be true okay
so you can write it in this Matrix
system of equations or you can write it
for a specific eigenvector t or
eigenvalue Lambda now here TK is just a
a single eigenvector corresponding to
that particular eigenvalue these come in
pairs is what I'm trying to say okay
let's take a big step back
uh we want to solve these systems
generically they are not going to be
diagonal we know that we like diagonal
systems because they're easy to solve
but generically they're not going to be
diagonal so we try to find a coordinate
transformation t a matrix T that can map
me into a new coordinate system like
literally you know Z is going to equal T
inverse
of X so I can go from X to this new
coordinate system Z so that Z has
diagonal decoupled Dynamics so it's easy
to solve my Dynamics in z
now if I go through some algebra we find
that this is the condition so if Z dot
these are the Dynamics in my Z
coordinates and so if I want these to be
diagonal then this has to be true and I
can rewrite that in terms of my
eigenvalue equation
so
this is the equation I solve to get that
eigenvector coordinate transformation T
that diagonalizes my Matrix a and given
that we're going to be able to solve
generic systems that are really nasty in
terms of easy easy easy linear algebra
okay and that's all coming up next in
the next lecture I'm going to show you
how do you actually compute eigenvalues
and eigenvectors and in the lecture
after that I'm going to show you how do
you use that to actually solve these
differential equations that we want all
right thank you
[Music]
foreign